I was sort of surprised by the vice
presidential debate yesterday in a few
ways but there was no doubt that Mike
Pence was more knowledgeable and
competent with regard to political
issues and early on in the debate it was
very clear that Tim Kaine seemed not
quite on his game and pence was doing
well at least in terms of the way that
it appeared and sounded as usual the way
it is with Republican candidates if you
don't listen to specifically to the
words that they're saying but later in
the debate Mike Pence really started to
sort of fall apart Tim Kaine really
brutalizing him and and the the best
tactic that Cain use the most
devastating way that Cain was able to
score points on Mike Pence was that Cain
kept putting Mike Pence in the position
to have to defend or very clearly not
defend Donald Trump's ideas and
statements and in many ways the vice
presidential debate is effectively about
the two top surrogates for the campaigns
making the case for the person at the
top of the ticket Tim Kaine for hillary
clinton and mike pence for Donald Trump
the Republican and when you were there
primarily to tell voters the person at
the top of the ticket is fantastic and
by the way if something were to happen
to them I'm competent to Mike Pence
didn't do that because Tim Kaine time
and again asked him to defend past
statements of Donald Trump's and Mike
Pence didn't do it sometimes just
redirecting sometimes denying that Trump
ever said it in the first place so one
example was this idea of well it's okay
if more countries have nukes more
countries deserve to have nukes Trump
talked about Saudi Arabia and other
countries Mike Pence taking the approach
of just denying that Donald Trump had
ever said that this was sort of his
tactic uh I guess partially hoping
people in the audience wouldn't look it
up because as usual and completely
predictably the hill hillary clinton
campaign has already put out a similar
video to the one they did after the
first presidential debate saying uh
basically verbatim here the denials from
Mike Pence and then here is video of
Donald Trump saying these exact
now I want to uh remind you that for
those of you who have seen the online
articles which say oh well Mike Pence
won the debate I don't disagree with
that Pat if you're just looking at tone
and style which i think is similar to
what you came away with yeah absolutely
if you don't watch the news every day I
could see how you would come away
thinking that pence one cuz he just did
much better job at just performance but
if you look at the points and break them
down I mean pence was not able to defend
any of trumps record no doubt about it
and this this is one of those areas I I
know that it it's in a way it's a shame
that we have to talk about more than
just the substance but we know dating
all the way back to I don't know the the
Kennedy Nixon debate that the optics of
these debates really matter in Tim Kaine
I don't know if partially it was the way
he had his chair position to the cameras
but when he would look at what was
clearly the debate moderator Elaine
Quijano it created a very weird angle in
terms of the split screen with pence
like he was almost looking away in a way
that just didn't look quite right he
shifted in his seat a lot he had sort of
nervous smirks and smiles which hey I I
understand when you've got pence they're
just lying through his teeth about what
Trump didn't didn't say did you get that
same sense that the way Cain looked
seemed uncomfortable yeah I absolutely
did and you could tell that Penn's his
shoulders were squared to the camera and
you would actually make eye contact with
the camera every now and then yep
whereas Cain kinda seems kind of smarmy
at times kept after interrupting and I
think that didn't really play well with
a lot of people watching now what Cain
did really well is he offered a list of
insults that Donald Trump has used about
other people and uh and and what was
interesting was hence didn't really take
the bait in the way that when Hillary
Clinton would say things that she was
trying to elicit a reaction from Trump
on Trump clearly so much less discipline
than Mike Pence Trump took the bait just
about every single time now i want to
get here to uh this this is going to be
some video and i have to explain this to
you because it's so insane tim kaine
listed a bunch of insults and statements
may
by Donald Trump and all of them are
based in fact and and if completely
defensible Mike Pence did something
which is either brilliant or stupid okay
pence acted as if Tim Kaine was just
rattling off insults all he was doing
was quoting Trump and pence did I don't
know if this slipped under the radar and
when people people may be less
sophisticated to use consumers thought
Pence is right Kane is insulting people
all Tim Kaine does is quote Trump and
then pence accuses Kane of using insults
take a look at this video Donald Trump
Donald Trump can't start a Twitter war
with Miss Universe without shooting
himself in the foot Donald Trump doesn't
have a plan he said I have a secret plan
and then he said no more than all the
generals about ISIL and then he said I'm
going to call the generals to help me
figure out a plan and finally he said
I'm going to fire all the generals he
doesn't have a plan but he does have
dangerous ideas here's for he trash
talks the military the militaries of
disaster John McCain's no hero the
generals need all to be fired and I know
more than them he wants to tear up
alliances NATO is obsolete and will only
work together with is Israel if they pay
big league third he loves dictators he's
got kind of a personal Mount Rushmore
right on your Putin Kim choice moammar
gadhafi khosadam insane and last and
most dangerously Donald Trump believes
Donald Trump believes that the world
will be safer in more nations have
nuclear weapons he said Saudi Arabia
should get him Japan should get him
Korea should get him and when he was
confronted with this and told wait a
minute Terrace could get those
proliferation could lead to nuclear war
here's what Donald Trump said and I
quote go ahead folks enjoy yourselves
I'd love to hear governor pence tell me
what's so enjoyable or comical about
nuclear war governor pence did you work
on that one a long time cuz that had a
lot of really creative lines in it well
I'm gonna see if you can look at any of
it look I can defend I I can i can make
very clear to the American people after
traveling millions of miles as our
Secretary of State after being the arc
attack chua Lee wasn't the insult clip
we'll get to the I got ahead of myself
we'll get to the insult clip later this
is the one where pence didn't defend
anything right he said I can defend all
of that stuff he defended absolutely
none of it he instead shifted into some
basic foreign policy talking points and
the reason pence would didn't defend it
is because it's indefensible there was
no rational basis on which this
accumulation of ideas from Donald Trump
over the campaign can be defended if you
understood what was going on in this
debate which was the Tim Kaine merely
reference things said by Donald Trump
and Mike Pence didn't defend a single
one he either redirected shifted into a
pseudo talking point coma or just denied
that those statements were ever made to
begin with this was devastating for Mike
Pence but yes based on optics alone I
sort of understand how you could come
away thinking Mike Pence one he seems
sort of calmer more relaxed and more
polished on that stage